so the first story we have here from
timcast.com lizzo twerks while playing
James Madison's flute at DC concert and
uh and that's it you know one of the uh
earliest presidents had a crystal Flute
from 1813 and the Library of Congress
brought that on stage to this woman so
that she could uh toot her flute and
twerk and something something about this
just it's a it's a it's a it's a circus
it's a spectacle it is I don't know what
the right word is for it but it seems
unserious like we've become a very
unserious people as a waste of taxpayer
dollars well yeah yeah but what I mean
is you know we used to be like we're
going to the Moon people not because we
want to but because we have to or
whatever I don't know what the quote was
but it was like you look back on history
and we see these very serious things
everything was a large matter of cons a
matter of consequence you've got Wars
you've got civil rights you've got all
of this huge historical stuff happening
and I look back on that I'm like either
the country is is completely fall apart
because we have no serious culture we're
permanently children you know good times
make weak men or it never existed in the
first place and we just romanticize the
past so so you're telling me James
Madison wasn't twerking and playing his
flute at the same time that's what he
would do yeah he would go up on stage
and he would you know twerk that was
very big in the late 70s yeah I thought
I thought what she did was very bold and
brave bold uh very bold uh and you know
the cloth stuck up her uh took us was
definitely an added uh artistic
expression that I think we have to fully
support because it's again something
that is uh is is nice now so uh so I
fully support it here's here's lizzo
tweeting nobody has ever heard this
famous Crystal flute before now you have
I'm the first and only person to ever
play this presidential 200 year old
Crystal flute thank you Library of
Congress you know I can appreciate this
she's very happy to be uh you know
playing this but there's something about
it that to me it's just kind of like
I don't think disrespectful is the right
word but is is desecration yeah that's a
creation of historical piece of History
it's a really neat piece of History it's
beautiful and she just no she upped the
value now you know lizzo played James
Madison's flute like her buttocks of a
flailing up and down making the clap
noise adds value to this historical
thing and now when we think of James
Madison's flute we think of the
wonderful
booty of Miss lizzo which uh I think
only makes it that much better
the first time
this reminds me of like idiocracy and
Wally
like like the look of shock and
excitement on her face
[Applause]
I think that comment was perfect right
there I just I just kind of feel like
you know we're we're on the verge of
World War III and Vladimir Putin's
sitting back in his chair and he's
watching this and he's like yeah it's
all over
you know what I mean you don't
understand the major accomplishment that
this was yes thank you Andrew finally
someone sees it like I do this is this
is Americana personified right in our
reality I mean what else do you need to
to see to understand that this is this
is America at its best right now I think
oh sorry go ahead no I was gonna say I
think the Chinese Engineers of tick tock
are the ones who are sitting back
laughing because if you're asking
yourself what does our culture pay
attention to well
that's what tick tock tick tock tick
tock culture will get you right there oh
man and and these Tick Tock videos they
pop up on Instagram too and I look at
them and I'm like okay people are being
programmed with this stuff like have you
seen these videos there's a lot of memes
and they play songs and they all do the
exact same thing and it's like
is degenerate the right word you know
depraved yeah yeah it's it's working on
basic impulse impulses and when you look
at Chinese Tick Tock and their algorithm
and you compare it to the American Tick
Tock and what is shown to our children
here that it's captivating so much of
their attention span that YouTube is
trying to copy every uh thing that Tick
Tock is right now you see a huge
difference uh with what is represented
to the children of China that are
limited on the platform only to uh I
believe an hour or two hours per day
they're shown educational content
they're shown content that that informs
them about things that about their
culture about their society about things
that they could be doing art uh math
science all of that is prioritized here
twerking sexuality degeneracy idiocy
hurting people making fun of people uh
and normalizing obesity normalizing uh
castration normalizing some of the most
craziest ideas which some people would
hint at is a form of fifth generational
Warfare with people being brainwashed
and doing things that essentially hurt
them their families their communities
and eventually the country and I think
this needs to be understood when it
comes to seeing the algorithm and its
larger impacts on society do you guys
ever take the um moral foundations test
you know that you know that one it's
based on Jonathan Heights research there
are six moral foundations you guys know
you know another one uh liberals have
only two
conservatives have all six and
Libertarians only have one of course
Libertarians and it's liberty everything
else yeah it's just Liberty so like well
Liz is free to do this they ask
questions
um to find out where your moral
foundations are I usually get what is
this it says like left liberal but I've
I have a decent balance uh across the
board but I have really high Liberty and
then I have really high like fairness
liberals only have care and fairness as
their moral foundations they have no uh
loyalty like sanctity Purity or whatever
the other ones are and then they have
very low Liberty on average and then
Libertarians they just don't care about
anything but Liberty so the questions
they ask you
it'll be like on there's a scale where
it's like how okay are you with this
scenario and one of them would be one of
them is uh Janet is cleaning her attic
when she comes across an old war
memorial flag from her grandfather's
time in a service and she picks it up
and uses a washcloth to scrub the floors
are you okay with this liberals tend to
say yeah who cares Libertarians tend to
say yeah who cares conservatives tend to
say this is not okay so in that regard I
actually say yeah absolutely not okay I
think for me it's like it's important to
recognize the past so that we can learn
from it understand it and improve moving
forward but when I see something like
this I don't I don't feel like Rage or
disgust I just kind of I kind of feel
like yeah we're going down we're going
downhill because there's there's a
certain amount of respect you would have
for objects and artifacts and things
that represent the successes and and the
failures of humanity and for this
spectacle of this big you know what's
the right word bodacious Bodacious yes
sure Luke but look look I'm not trying
to be mean to to lizzo because you know
I'm fairly I got that libertarian Spike
but what I see here is American history
being mocked essentially by a morbidly
obese woman on stage as a spectacle as a
gag as a joke totally disrespecting what
it is what it represents what it's
supposed to be and as Luke was saying
it's it's the normalization all of all
of these really negative traits that
we're supposed to be okay with I look at
this and I feel like it's idiocracy I
feel like it's Wally you know in Wally
everybody's morbidly obese they have no
bone density anymore that's that's not
the kind of place we want to go we don't
want to go into some future where
everyone's like He-Man ripped and like
it's sparred or anything like that but
the very least we can be like hey you
know we're gonna respect the the relics
of our past so we can understand it this
to me is just like taking a dump on the
American flag you know do you think the
people would have said the same thing in
the late 1960s like you know
conservatives at the time would have
said America's going down the toilet
this is it it's over like because
America does to a certain extent
oscillate between conservative and no
for sure culture right and I've thought
about that so I decided you know what
this could just be our generation's
conflict so I asked a bunch of older
people who were around back then they
said certainly not
they said it's never been this bad so
maybe we're just oscillating downwards
yeah I think we are I went to I went to
an antique shop it's amazing uh I got a
photo I got books uh it's the
photographic history of the Civil War
it's his collection it's from 1913 I
think it's very expensive and it's
amazing you opened up and there's
pictures from like Civil War
battlefields and stuff and I asked this
guy was in his 60s have have you ever
seen it this bad and he says no
absolutely not now granted in the 60s he
was you know that's around the time he
was born uh he was he was a small child
but I've asked a bunch of older people
too because uh people we've had on the
show we've had a lot of people on the
show who are like in their 70s and older
and they all say the same thing it has
never been this bad so I have to wonder
you know well here's maybe just one
question here
do you also think that the power of
information and technology and the way
in which ideas can basically go between
groups of people go between countries in
a way that they never could before like
to at a certain point the top is going
to blow off and people will awaken to
the fact that they've been you know
controlled in these paradigms like what
we're looking at right there and
everybody's celebrating you know you
know what I you know what I wonder is
there seems to be
independent thinkers and dependent
thinkers and I wonder what the Catalyst
for that is why is it that some people
want to live in The Matrix and some
people don't is this something inherent
to an individual down to their core
their soul or is it a learned behavior
or something that could at least be
snapped out of I certainly think humans
are amorphous to the point where anyone
can be red pilled anyone can be woke it
doesn't matter where you're from but I
wonder if there's a tendency due to
something you know inherent I'm not
saying I know for sure I'm wondering I
guess I think that that battle happens
has happened since America was accepted
it's between the Puritans who settled
you know in the mass Bay colonies wrote
the first laws in the United States like
one of the first laws written in the
United States was you can't beat your
wife with a stick any thicker than your
thumb I don't think that's true yes it
is
let's look it up I think that's a
microphone no it's it's literally that
there are like 12 laws that were written
in the mass Bay colonies and that's one
of them
let's check it out anyways there's then
there were the hillbillies who also came
and they conquered the frontier and
they're like I'm not going to listen to
your laws I'm not going to listen to
that I think to a certain extent America
is unique in that we have those two
cultures kind of battling it out
uh let's see
English jurist Sir William Blackstone
wrote in the commentaries of the laws of
England an old law that wants moderate
beatings by husbands but he did not
mention thumbs yeah I'm pretty sure
that's apocryphal
so when you search for this you get rule
of thumb and they say that the rule of
thumb is not a real thing um yeah I'm
talking about beating your wife with a
stick thicker than your thumb but that's
where they that's where that comes from
so well that's what people are saying it
it's based on you know that the rule of
thumb is about beating your wife when
it's actually so there's a courtroom in
1824 that asserted this
wait uh a ruling in Mississippi state
that the man was entitled to enforce
domestic discipline by striking his wife
with a whip or stick no wider than the
judge's Thumb in a later case in 1868
the defendant was found to have struck
his wife with a switch with the size of
his fingers the judge found the man not
guilty due to the switch being smaller
than the thumb so I don't know man you
don't don't beat your wife it's not cool
well clearly clearly that was aside from
it yeah well I don't think this is my I
think this is my take on the whole as a
situation I don't think it's that deep
I don't first of all did anybody in this
room
know the existence of that flute before
today no no no and it's very cool what
okay James Madison apparently never
played it so it was probably just given
to him like somebody made it that makes
it worse we don't know the historical
significance of this flu other than
James Madison probably got it during his
presidency
lizzo absolutely did not know about that
flute she had a concert there somebody
in the National Archives is probably
like I really like this and we have this
stupid flute that nobody's played and
it's it's like let me let me answer
sorry it's like Pixar it's like Pixar
okay John Lasseter used to have like a
in his office he used to have all the
Pixar toys and then little kids would
want to touch him and he's like no no
don't touch him and he's like well wait
a minute their toys kids should be
allowed to play them and the National
Archives is probably the same thing like
that flute needs to be played right so
that makes it worse right if you if you
had an original sealed Han Solo action
figure mint condition and then someone
was like let's tear it open and play
with it you destroy the value of it the
fact that it's preserved is what makes
it valuable but if you're George Lucas
who cares like you're just like sure kid
go play right this is America this is
the property of the American public that
was never played before was a historical
artifact was handed off to some
Entertainer to play on stage and that's
why I said desecration
it's it's it's no longer this pristine
Crystal flute that was ornamental it is
now a gag prop for for a stage show it's
not like she pooped on an American flag
I mean she just like played a flute for
five seconds I mean it's I I wouldn't
necessarily call it desecration I would
say the whole situation is like I'm not
I'm trying I'm not trying to say that
it's like akin to like pissing on a
grave or anything but like it has
fundamentally altered what that object
was and I just think what we see
consistently is this this idea that
these people uh you know typically on
the left care absolutely nothing for
this country they call it historically
racist they crap all over it and it's
all hypocrisy they're more than happy to
say defund the police but then call the
police on people they don't like they're
more than happy to to all laugh and
cheer and scream 1619 project but then
be like we get to play with this
historical artifact it's just
what I see is you can certainly look to
the Past in your country and and and say
hey there were bad things and we want to
do away with those but I think you
absolutely have to respect you know the
beginnings of where you come from and
the history of your country I think look
what it comes down to is the reverence
for this country is is just flushed on
the toilet and this is this may just be
a grain of sand in the Heap but this is
like a big show where they pulled from
the archives from the Library of
Congress and brought it on stage to make
some spectacle out of I'm not saying
it's the apocalypse but it's not I'm not
like significant either the actual flu
like you know we don't we don't know
what it's about like who gave it to him
like why was it given it why was it made
I don't think that's relevant
like I've got I've got a coin uh I've
got I've got a coin from Athens you know
that I got at a shop I don't know who
spend it I don't know why it was for a
you know a minted no idea all I know is
that it exists it's it's it's evidence
of the civilization that existed it's
it's a reminder of these things I was
also uh I got this for Sheamus it was a
coin used by Saint Casper that uh well
they they alleged it was it was one of
the same coins that were were minted
around the same time that was given to
St Casper was one of the wise men it may
have been used by him we don't know for
sure but this was the the these were the
ones minted in this area where they
believe you came from and that's a
representation of something valuable
using it as currency is meaningless but
to like to take these items and treat
them like just spectacles and toys or
gag shows I think is is look no no one
desecration I think is like a signal of
the Apocalypse that's the gag I put in
the title of this video I just think
that this is just another sign of the
decay of the core and the soul of this
country thanks for checking out this
segment from the timcast IRL podcast but
if you want to check out the full show
live tune in Monday through Friday at 8
pm and if you want more special access
content head over to timcast.com and
become a member your membership helps
sustain this company keep our
journalists employed makes this show
happen and you will get access to
exclusive members only segments of the
timcast IRL podcast and there's a
massive library to check out so again go
to timcast.com or tune in Monday through
Friday at 8pm and we'll see you all
there